so when you hear like when when jay-z
puts out that song on the Black Album
where he says he would like to be you
you're sitting there thinking well I
wanted to be you actually at very
accurate I was like can we trade places
for a second I can maybe have your bank
account for a day and I'll flip it
no jay-z I mean you know all due respect
to jay-z jay-z is infinitely more rich
than I am and infinitely more popular
than I am but he you know he's
referenced me in song and if you listen
to his new album yeah Jay I've always
been a fan of jay-z's so much where I
said jay-z will get the real jay-z
when he doesn't have to worry about
fourth-quarter sales when he's
comfortable in his and and doesn't have
to worry about whether or not people
gonna buy the record when he's already
rich that's we're gonna get the real
jay-z and that's what we're getting now
he's rhyming about his relationships and
his babies and he's any sampling Nina
Simone twice when the side yeah you know
my biggest record doesn't mean a small
sample you know years ago jay-z said ah
you know I want to wrap my quality in
common I feel like now he's getting to
yeah this I mean it's it's a super like
I think some people were even taken
aback with the new jay-z album because
there aren't any real like bangers on it
it's all and it's very common as long as
you like sing along to really they're
kind of like it's a more vulnerable ham
kinda yeah it's grown and um you know
there was a couple of websites talking
about jay-z made the first grown hip hop
now maybe the first grown hip hop album
for people who aren't familiar with hip
hop but that sort of a race is a lot of
the artists that were did jay-z himself
has referenced as inspirations for what
he did now he even put out a playlist
last week when I'm dropped of the artist
he's been listening to to show you like
listen I'm influenced by other artists
let hers there's artists out there that
have been making that type of album but
jay-z is like so rich and famous that
when he does it is like now everybody
pays attention and he's just [ __ ]
brilliant at the craft - what's your
relationship like with Kanye now cuz
like when Kanye first came out you were
on the first album he was producing your
songs like he was shouting you out on
other songs like are you guys still well
Kanye Kanye I consider I to this day I
consider Kanye a great friend yeah I
think he's an icon he mean he'll tell
you himself he's an icon a genius and
happened to agree um you know I think
he's literally given me life that's it
that's a cliched phrase oh this thing
gave me life and it's like Kanye litter
gave me life you know in the studio his
energy on tour he's produced some of my
biggest records he's been instrumental
to my career not just in my career but
to artists like me like mos def and
common and Lupe Fiasco and other artists
that he's lending his ear and a sound to
um I don't I'm not a trump supporter at
all and I'm not a fan of Trump and I'm
not a fan of artists standing with
Donald Trump so when he when he when he
stood with Donald Trump at least
publicly I was disappointed by that and
I don't have a relationship with Kanye
he Kanye is like a super famous
stratosphere out there like he's
achieved a level of Fame that I have no
relationship with yeah so I don't it's
not like I can get him on the phone at
this point I could maybe two years ago
but I can't right now but Kanye
complained last year about not being
able to get jay-z on the phone he
complained publicly on stage I remember
right so when he complained publicly on
stage about not being able to take
another phone that made me feel like I
could publicly say something to him you
know and so I publicly said listen the
Trump stuff I'm not I'm not I'm not with
that but beyond that I mean look the man
is an icon and he's a genius and and you
know I if I if I can't be honest with
him about things that I disagree with
him about I can't really be a friend
Kanye said a lot of things that have
upset people mm-hmm then I was able to
and and I haven't agreed with everything
he said but everything he said up to the
Trump thing I rode with him more like
maybe I don't agree but he has a right
to say in his name that's the one thing
that I that I publicly was like I'm not
I'm not really feeling him on that
could you get jay-z on the phone mm it
might take a month jay-z was on the
remix forget by yeah so I you know I I I
met jay-z at the roots did a Lincoln
Center thing right as get by was blowing
up and jay-z was like my favorite rapper
at the time and I met him backstage and
there's there's like footage this
footage on the Internet
of the first time I met jay-z and meet
like fanboying out over jay-z like it's
like jay-z meeting me and we're showing
each other mutual respect and I'm super
nervous and it's like ten years ago so
my closer super big falling off of me
and and then I'm I asked him to be on
the song and we exchanged two-way pager
Wow
yeah machine line it up with the machine
yeah and we exchanged two ways and um I
hit him like for like three months maybe
four times to the point where I felt
like I was being a Bugaboo and I left it
alone and then one day and my email
unday he sent me a two way page and said
I'm gonna eat what's your email my email
you this this verse and I looked at my
email and the verse was it we never had
a conversation he just sent me the verse
and then I saw him at a party and I
thanked him for the verse I was like I
was like is he giving you the verse like
he's like this for you yeah I was like
how much is that how much he was like
I'm not gonna charge you because you
can't afford what I charge for versus he
charged who does he charge each are just
someone who he doesn't have the same
level of mutual respect I guess I guess
he just wanted to do any probably like
you and wanted to do something now he he
said he told me he said if I charge you
that would be your whole budget you know
and he was right and so but then the
record came out and was on the radio for
like two weeks and jay-z was still
signed at Def Jam at the time Lyoko and
heard it and sent a cease-and-desist out
so they had to stop playing the record
why because that's T at that time he was
a Def Jam artists so Lyon was like what
is jay-z do one on this underground rap
record like nah you know I'm not oh yeah
yes how the labels do like so that's I
think stuff like that than that jay-z
was like I need to have my own I need to
own Rockefeller I need to have Rock
nation I need to all title I need to be
able to make my own decision what was a
young Kanye like to work with the same
as Kanye now he was the same that's the
beauty of Kanye is when I met him like
this is a real story like when you talk
about speaking truth to power
you talk about like like like like just
controlling your fate I've watched this
man create his own destiny like I
watched him say I am going to be known
for wearing more polar than anyone and
I'm going to have this the bear as my
album cover my first Psalms college
dropout my second albums late
registration the third was gonna be
called graduation he said all it is
before he had a record deal you know he
was like he played me jesus walks he
played me um hey mama he played me all
these records
and I'm like yo this how this record is
grazin ami I'm gonna get a deal I'm
gonna put this at this song on my second
album it's crazy you know saying like he
had it all mapped out yeah he knew what
he wanted to do yeah exactly and that
was inspirational to me because like I
was I was famous before Kanye before 50
cent and I remember 2004 they both came
out and they were both huge and they
were competing they handed records
against each other and these were both
artists who were referencing me and I
was like okay seeing how they planned
their [ __ ] out it just made me work a
lot harder and sort of reinvigorated my
career I was closed I wasn't as close to
50 at all but I was close to Kanye and
seeing them seeing how they they planned
it out really made me say okay I got to
revisit what I'm doing